поїдете і до ряду проекту прем'єр-міністра
голосів на екстреному засіданні експерт
і не вірити на їхню донгуз гра на
публіку для спокійніший вибір тиф і
західних партнерів до них можна пробувати
і всі будинки разом з після скандальної
вид ставка міністра абромавічуса і його
зайняв все розміщую ремені дисплеєм з
брехт і чаплиною і натще не народний
валютний фонд дати гаю ніж вуда
безвізовий режим на дуже багато factory
за галя дави роду україною а збоку
міжнародній сфері, але ти в такій на
чоловіків та
міністрів і тисне ставку та владне
ефірі для повороту я думаю буду шаман
для українця момент істини і значить там
ще україна n'est pas можна тут немає
реформ flash навчених заяв
прем'єр-міністра проїде не кума одну
гру недоліки для переконань
європейців стане зайвим прохання мішу
поряд адміністрацію президента а
також стан ременя куру
провалювання реформ уварити краще
забудьте кислого поважають експерти тепер
є папір там образки його конкретних і
чітких де
може диви то синові розумом і для у трюму
недоступного транші виглядом у f10 але все
простіше стрибати лишай за розумом у занурення
чітко їх ви міг заходу перша з давніх
харчування сюди г.п.
я командувала до кінця жадібність право
producer розум повних високого саду
тепер апогей на майдані одразу милість
шокін маяки ти інша надмірного кт і
вниз правої руки порошенка ігоря
кононенко накласти 7 з відразу
мило поставити на порядок дані ось
ніч з сама ставку міністра
абромавічус а е зможе стерпить і проти
і 6 за розумом і ліцей скандал виробляючи до
реальних зрад у краї не йду реальну
прохання з корупцією лю дають експерти
і наші
дувер західних партнерів буде
досить втрачена